hey everyone in this video we'll be
doing a side-by-side comparison of mario
party 2 to the brand new mario party
superstars with footage i captured of
both a few things to note before we
begin the original version of mario
party 2 is an n64 game but the capture
used in this video is the n64 version
running on wii u virtual console and
mario party superstars is captured on a
nintendo switch also mario party 2 is
running at 30 frames per second while
mario party superstars runs at 60 frames
per second so you'll notice one is
smoother than the other if you like this
video and want to see more comparisons
like it then consider subscribing to
gamespot so without further ado let's
get going to the world of mario party
old and new
[Music]
yes
[Music]
winners
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
finish
[Music]
what's that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fish
[Music]
start
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
finish
winner
[Applause]
[Music]
start
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
finish
stats
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
start
[Music]
finish
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you like this
video then consider dropping a like it
helps more than you'd think if you're
interested in seeing more mario party
superstars videos we have a video review
on this channel and some gameplay on our
second channel links to both of those
can be found in the description for
everything mario and nintendo stay tuned
to gamespot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you